Question 1 - Potato Bomb asks, Osgood from
the 50th is in the trailer with her inhaler.
Does she have anything to do with Missy.
She seemed like she fancied him?
Question 2 - Alex asks, do you think Missy
created Clara, created her to be the impossible
girl and she’s also the girl
in the shop who gave
clara
the doctor’s phone number?
Question 3 - Mitchell asks, Clara said she
didn’t want to be the last of her kind.
Do you think she and the Doctor forgot they
saved Gallifrey during the 50th?
Question 4 - Adam asks, Do you think Missy
created the solar flare to test the Doctor?
Question 5 - Hand of God asks, do you think
that mysterious Ginger Girl will be
the
next companion?
Question 6 - Sax Ops asks, what if heaven
is a cyber conversion factory?
Question 7 - Mr Big Rollin asks, do you think
we’ll see more two parters next season?
Question 8 - Je Moeder asks, what role do
you think UNIT is going to play in the finale?
Question 9 - Harrison asks, how long do
you think it’s going to
be
before the Doctor regenerates into someone
new?
Question 10 - Sacha asks do you think Missy
is trying to get revenge on The Doctor?
It seems like she’s saving people who have
sacrificed themselves.